comment allez-vous la dernière fois où
c'était la fois d'avant ou encore celle
d'avant bon en tout cas parmi les 32
dernières vidéos histoire il y en a une
qui était une histoire de survie qui
racontait l'histoire d'un mec qui a
survécu sur son radeau de sauvetage
pendant deux mois tout seul au milieu de
la mer et j'ai adoré ça pour deux
raisons la première c'est de voir
comment il a fait pour survivre sachant
que moi je pense que je ne tiens pas
deux jours à sa place et la deuxième
c'est aussi de voir un peu l'impact
psychologique que ça et ce qui se passe
un peu dans ton cerveau d'humain quand
tu es un niveau de détresse aussi vénère
quand tu es aussi proche finalement de
mourir alors des histoires comme ça il
en existe plein mais il y en a une qui a
attiré mon attention récemment cette
fois ça se passe pas en mer ça se passe
en Antarctique vous savez le continent
où il y a que des scientifiques parce
que c'est invivable aujourd'hui je vais
vous raconter l'expédition
cauchemardesque d'un très célèbre
explorateur australien qui s'appelle
cire Douglas Mawson et croyez-moi si
vous avez déjà un peu peur des
conditions extrêmes du froid et tout
après cette vidéo vous détesterez encore
plus donc là smawson n'est en 1892 en
Angleterre mais attention il poursuit sa
vie à Sidney en Australie devient donc
australien voilà j'ai pas raconté deux
histoires de suite où ça concerne des
anglais ça va oh faut savoir que lui son
truc c'est les sciences c'est vraiment
sa passion et d'ailleurs va en faire ses
études puisqu'il va faire des études de
géologie et d'ingénierie en 1903 après
ces études il participe à une expédition
géologique au Vanuatu tout naturellement
c'est lui donne envie d'en faire plus et
4 ans plus tard vu qu'il a kiffé l'île
paradisiaque il décide de faire une
expédition à un endroit opposé à une île
paradisiaque une expédition en
Antarctique pourquoi il est amené à
faire cette expédition là parce qu'à
l'époque toutes les nations elle se
livre une méga compétition il y a une
sorte de méga concours de [ __ ] et en
gros c'est celui qui aura exploré le
plus de terre en Antarctique qui gagne
du coup ceux qui sont prêts à les
risquer leur vie là-bas parce que c'est
des conditions vraiment extrêmes ils
sont grassement payés par le
gouvernement à tel point que les
explorateurs qui vont là-bas on les
appelle les héros de l'Antarctique et le
bon Douglas évidemment il veut sa part
du gâteau il rejoint l'expédition Nîmes
rod en 1907 et il fait partie des
premiers hommes à atteindre le pôle sud
magnétique et c'est aussi l'un des
premiers hommes à gravir le mont Erebus
un volcan de 3800 mètres le plus au sud
de la terre
beau gosse il est donc en 1910 invité à
participer à l'expédition Terranova qui
a pour but d'atteindre le pôle Sud
géographique je connais super bien la
différence entre les deux mais on n'a
pas le temps on va passer à l'aise on
parle d'une expédition colossale et les
participants c'est que des gros noms du
explorateur game Douglas refuse pourquoi
parce que c'est Douglas mon pote et
Douglas il veut monter sa propre
expédition là vous vous dites sûrement
comme moi quand j'ai lu ça [ __ ] l'ego
du mec fais là l'expédition qu'est-ce
que tu racontes là eux je vais faire mon
truc et ben sachez un truc refuser de
participer à cette expédition ça lui a
tout simplement sauver la vie tout le
monde est mort dans cette expédition
c'est
rigolo parce qu'ils sont tous
l'expédition Terranova c'était un échec
non seulement parce que tout le monde
est mort au moment du retour mais aussi
parce que en arrivant sur place il y
avait des Norvégiens qui étaient déjà
arrivés 30 jours avant
j'écoute explorer pas des terres jamais
visitées par l'homme d'explorer un truc
n'hésitez pas d'énorvégiens 30 jours
plus tôt ce qui est beaucoup moins
prestigieux bref on est en 1911 et
Douglas il commence à planifier son
expédition l'expédition de l'Antarctique
le nom est pas ouf soyons honnêtes son
but est simple un peu comme toutes les
expéditions de l'époque c'est mener des
missions scientifiques et cartographiées
l'endroit et aussi tant qu'à faire il
revendiquer des territoires pour
l'Australie on sait jamais voilà Douglas
comme vos youtubeurs et streamer
préférés a donc besoin de trouver des
sponsors mais lui il va pas se faire
sponsoriser par nordvpn rhinoshield non
non il réussit je sais pas comment à se
faire financer par le roi d'Angleterre
directement mais aussi le gouvernement
australien au cas où en backup et aussi
quelques compagnies minières il réunit
donc une somme d'argent importante grâce
à laquelle il va pouvoir s'entourer de
90 personnes c'est 90 personnes ça
donnera cinq groupes de personnes
différentes qui mèneront chacun une
expédition différente sur place et
Douglas pour son gros il choisit que
deux personnes moi j'en aurai pris genre
22 pour être sûr d'être bien le premier
c'est le lieutenant Belgrave ni Nice
fusillé Royal anglais qui était déjà là
lors de l'expédition de Nimrod que de
glace a fait le deuxième homme c'est
Xavier Mertz un champion olympique de
ski
ça a du sens attendez parce que sur
place ils vont se déplacer en traîneau
le traîneau c'est proche du ski Douglas
va charger ce champion olympique de ski
de s'occuper des 48 husky qui traîneront
les traîneaux pendant l'expédition ça se
trouve le mec il a même pas un chien
chez lui là il doit s'occuper de 48 bref
on a les hommes les chiens le matériel
le bateau l'Aurora a un ancien bateau de
chasse à la baleine habitué aux eaux
glaciales et le départ est prévu pour le
28 juillet 1911 le voyage dure 5 mois
5 mois les gars nous on est lessivés
après avoir pris le train ou l'avion 3
heures là sur place première étape
évidemment créer un abri une base dans
laquelle passer l'hiver cette base ils
vont l'appeler le cap Denison en honneur
au plus gros par un expédition young
denisum ce style un peu genre tu
finances des expéditions et du coup il y
a des bases en ton nom je vous arrête
tout de suite le cap des nyson c'est à
chier en gros le camp ils l'ont fait à
un endroit qui est considéré comme l'un
des endroits où il y a le plus de vents
au monde il y a des rafales mon poste
pas des rafales de vent c'est des
rafales d'AK47 et surtout souvenez-vous
on est en Antarctique en plein hiver les
températures on est sur en moyenne entre
-10 et - 60 degrés il y a beau avoir des
husky mignon et plein de gens c'est
quand même pas la fête du slip et
construise donc plein de huttes pour
accommoder tout le monde et dans ses
huttes il fait 4 degrés c'est comme si
là vous décidiez de passer la nuit dans
votre frigo c'est peut-être bon pour la
peau mais pas pour l'esprit bref nous
sommes le 10 novembre 1912 les 5 groupes
sont maintenant formés et partent tous
dans des directions différentes tout le
monde doit être de retour maximum le 15
janvier 1913 parce que c'est tout
simplement la date où le bateau l'Aurora
se casse et il y a une raison à ça c'est
que le risque de nouveau de former la
glace glace qui va bloquer le bateau et
malheureusement ils ont pas assez de vif
pour passer des mois tous ensemble ici
avant de pouvoir repartir l'info est
bien retenue et tout le monde part avec
l'ambition de revenir en héros Douglas
Xavier et Ninis partent pleines leur
objectif est simple il doit atteindre
une zone qui s'appelle hots et qui a 500
km de la base pendant 5 semaines tout se
passe bien ils font des relevés
scientifiques et s'habitue au terrain
qui les entoure et là premier problème
parmi les chiens qu'ils ont emmenés se
trouvent deux femelles qui mettent bas
et évidemment vu les conditions ils
peuvent pas s'occuper des portées après
une longue réflexion Douglas va tout
simplement tuer les chiots et les donner
à manger aux autres chiens sauf que
c'est un moment horrible pour les trois
hommes et encore plus pour ninice et
Xavier qui a été vraiment attaché au
chien je vous le rappelle avec qui ils
ont fait le trajet de 5 mois sur le
bateau ils avaient rien d'autre à [ __ ]
que des caresser les chiens et puis les
jours passent ces nouveaux problèmes
encore plus chiant l'expédition devient
beaucoup plus périlleuse que prévu en
gros le quotidien de nos trois amis
c'est de marcher sauf qu'en Antarctique
il y a plein de crevasses des crevasses
et des trous d'un coup dans le sol qui
peuvent faire jusqu'à 50 mètres de
profondeur en gros tu tombes dedans
c'est ciao merci pour ta contribution au
revoir des soucis c'est qu'à cause de la
neige il est très dur de repérer les
crevasses qu'est-ce que vous dites c'est
ça nouveau problème le lieutenant ni
Nice devient temporairement aveugle à
cause des puissants reflets du soleil
sur la neige en gros il a la rétine
sensible et le soleil tape tellement
fort que ça lui crame la rétine et comme
on Antarctique tout est blanc et tout
reflète le soleil peu importe où il
regarde il est baisé vu la dangerosité
du terrain sur lequel il avance c'est un
peu relou on va pas se mentir et aussi
il a quelques doigts qui gèlent et donc
de temps en temps Douglas doit lui en
1/6 comme ça un quotidien tout à fait
normal mais ça ne suffit pas il leur
faut encore plus de problèmes un jour
l'un des trois traîneaux qu'il
transporte avec eux tombent dans une
crevasse il est malheureusement
irrécupérable et la Douglas prend une
décision maline il se dit bon ce truc
des crevasses ça devient insupportable
et beaucoup trop dangereux donc ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va mettre tous nos
vivres et nos ressources vitales sur un
traîneau qui sera à l'arrière et qui
sera dirigé par ni Nice qui a la moins
bonne visibilité du groupe le deuxième
traîneau lui sera à l'avant on y mettra
tout notre matériel et il sera dirigé
par Xavier qui sera chargé de checker
autour et prévenir ni s'il voit une
crevasse honnêtement c'est malin et
comme tous les gens dans ces histoires
une capacité d'adaptation assez folle
face à ce qui les entoure et grâce à ça
ils ont déjà parcouru 500 km et ils sont
à deux doigts d'atteindre leur
destination et de faire demi-tour pour
rentrer à la base mais
[Musique]
calmez-vous le 13 décembre 1912 ils sont
en train de marcher et Xavier aperçoit
une crevasse au milieu de la neige il
lève le point il a l'air que le groupe
il contourne la crevasse et il continue
son chemin quelques minutes plus tard il
se retourne pour dire un truc à Douglas
et il constate que derrière Douglas il y
a plus une hélice immédiatement ils font
demi-tour il marche pendant plusieurs
minutes en hurlant son nom et puis ils
atteignent la fameuse crevasse que
Xavier avait repéré quelques minutes
plus tôt et au fond de cette crevasse se
trouve le corps de deux chiens et le
traîneau en revanche Ninis ne se trouve
pas au fond de la crevasse Douglas et
Xavier vont chercher ce jour-là pendant
plusieurs heures et ils ne vont jamais
le retrouver ils ne savent pas ce qui
est arrivé à Nice ils ont des théories
peut-être qu'il est tombé dans la
crevasse qu'il est mort sur le coup et
que son corps et au fin fond de la
crevasse n’est donc pas visible depuis
la surface peut-être aussi qu'il est
tombé qu'il est juste blessé et qu'il a
essayé de remonter à la surface via un
autre chemin bref il n'en savent rien
tout ce qu'ils savent c'est que leur ami
a disparu et qu'il le retrouveront
jamais donc là c'est Xavier sont donc au
milieu d'un environnement extrêmement
hostile à 500 km de la base avec plus
aucune nourriture ils sont clairement
foutus mais c'est des explorateurs c'est
des guerriers et ils prennent tout de
suite les choses mais avant toute chose
nouveau problème souvenez-vous le bateau
l'Aurora quitte le camp le 15 janvier il
leur reste donc un mois pour parcourir
les 500 km retour et atteindre le bateau
ils font le tour de toutes les options
et malheureusement il y en a que deux la
première c'est rejoindre la côte où il
pourrait se nourrir des phoques donc
régler le problème de nourriture et
espérer tomber sur un autre groupe
d'explorateurs malheureusement la côte
elle est à 500 km de leur position et
pour y aller c'est le même genre de
chemin que ce qui vient de faire c'est
des crevasses partout et rien ne les
assure une fois sur place de trouver de
l'aide la deuxième option c'est de
couper par les terres ce qui leur
permettrait d'atteindre la base beaucoup
plus rapidement et d'éviter tous les
reliefs dangereux les crevasses etc le
problème de cette option là c'est que
sur le chemin il y aura aucun animal à
chasser Douglas choisi la deuxième
option et pour résoudre ce problème de
nourriture il a une solution manger les
chiens le lendemain matin la fin se fait
ressentir ils sont épuisés et ils se
résignent à abattre un premier chien et
mange donc ce premier chien et c'est un
moment horrible puisque déjà l'avion est
dégueulasse et en plus c'était un
compagnon de route vous êtes prêts à
avoir des animaux bah voilà imaginez
demain vous devez tuer votre chat ou
votre chien pour voilà bref vous avez
compris les jours passent et tous les
jours c'est la même chose c'est ce truc
macabre d'abattre un chien et de le
manger pour pouvoir survivre mais on
arrive au stade où il y a plus assez de
chiens pour tirer les traîneaux Douglas
et Xavier doivent le pousser à la force
de leur brasse qui les épuise et donc
pour limiter la casse ils vont se
débarrasser de tout le matériel inutile
les instruments scientifiques les fusils
l'appareil photo tout ce qui est inutile
à leur survie est abandonné le 29
décembre les deux hommes abattent leur
dernier chien et vu qu'ils sont
débarrassés de leur fusil cette fois
c'est au couteau qui l'a battent ils ont
plus tient et donc plus nourriture il
pousse même le traîneau et du coup il
progresse plus que de 8 km par jour
autrement dit l'Aurora sera parti bien
avant qu'ils atteignent le camp si
jamais ils réussissent à l'atteindre là
on se dit bon ils sont au plus bas il
peut arriver que du bien maintenant
nouveau problème Xavier ton gravement
malade et son état ne cesse de se
détériorer faut savoir que pendant toute
l'expédition Douglas prend des notes
dans son carnet et ce jour là Douglas il
explique dans son carnet que la nuit
régulièrement Xavier se réveille et
hurle pendant des heures le 7 janvier
Xavier craque complètement comme chaque
nuit il se réveille comme chaque nuit il
hurle pendant des heures mais cette nuit
là il essaie de détruire la brique qui
permet aux deux hommes de survivre lors
des nuits glaciales Douglas tente de le
maîtriser se jette sur lui s'allonge sur
lui le bloc Xavier finit par se calmer
et apparemment quelques heures après cet
incident Xavier lâche son dernier
souffle les scientifiques pensent avec
leur culte en fait en mangeant les fois
des chiens et s'empoisonner à petit feu
à cause d'une abondance de vitamine A
qui est à haut dose toxique pour l'homme
donc non seulement ils étaient déjà dans
la merde mais qu'en plus qui mangeait ça
les affaiblissait au final puisque ça
les empoisonner bref on en est de se
calvaire donc là c'est maintenant seul
et il estime qu'il est environ 160 km de
la base alors il sait qu'il atteindra
pas le bateau à temps mais il espère
qu'avant de partir les explorateurs
laisseront au camp des provisions au cas
où Douglas atteignent le camp par
miracle Douglas continue de marcher seul
il a probablement longtemps à vivre
devant lui et un jour une énorme douleur
le prend au pied il retire ses bottes
pour voir ce qui se passe et là il voit
tranquillement la plante de ses pieds se
décoller la douleur évidemment est
insoutenable et il décide de bidouiller
un truc pour avoir moins mal il met de
la cire sur son pied il met plein de
paires de chaussettes il remet sa botte
et il se dit pitié ça tient il parle de
la peau de son pied la pitié ça tient
malgré tout et réussit à parcourir 8 km
de plus dans cet état on est le 17
janvier et la devinez quoi nouveau
problème il a pas le droit de souffler
Douglas apparemment la naissance on lui
a dit toi jamais tu respires fallait
bien que ça arrive il tombe dans une
crevasse heureusement la corde qu'il
relie à son traîneau n'a pas cédé le
traîneau est toujours à la surface et
Douglas réussi avec ses dernières forces
à remonter la corde atteindre son
traîneau et de nouveau pouvoir reprendre
sa route 10 jours plus tard bonne
nouvelle une bonne nouvelle les gars
c'est pas une blague donc là ça perso au
loin un petit monument de pierre posé au
milieu de rien ces petits monuments de
pierre c'est une façon utilisé par les
explorateurs pour se laisser des
messages et le message en l'occurrence
est plutôt cool un groupe de son
expédition est apparemment actuellement
à sa recherche et avec le message se
trouve de la nourriture le message date
d'appel 6 heures ça veut dire que
l'Aurora le bateau n'est pas encore
parti que les gens d'expédition ne l'ont
pas encore abandonné clairement ils
retrouvent l'espoir et retrouve
l'énergie malheureusement le temps
presse la date à laquelle l'Aurora
devait partir et maintenant passer et il
risque donc de partir à tout moment
avant d'être prisonniers de la glace à
cause d'un Blizzard de glace à ralenti
et arrive plus tard que prévu au camp et
à son arrivée il voit l'Aurora très loin
l'horizon en train de se barrer alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le 8 février 3
semaines après le départ initialement
prévu l'équipage n'ayant aucun signe de
vie de Douglas a décidé de partir mais
six hommes se sont portés volontaire au
moment du départ pour rester au camp au
cas où Douglas serait encore vivant eux
c'est vraiment des beaux gosses comment
je serai sur l'Aurora à moi à leur place
Douglas finit donc par croiser les six
hommes en question et ils vont ensemble
passer l'hiver à la base avec assez de
provisions pour survivre en attendant le
retour du bateau un an après son départ
le aura revient donc chercher les 7
hommes au cap de l'ison et c'est la fin
de l'horreur pour Douglas
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle waouh
Douglas n'a pas traversé toutes ses
épreuves pour rien il s'en sort vivant
indemne pas sûr mais vivant à son retour
en Australie il est accueilli comme un
héros ça devient une telle fierté
nationale que sa tête se retrouve sur
des billets de 100 dollars pendant
plusieurs années c'est bon sachez que
malgré tout ça Douglas est retourné
plusieurs fois dans tactique pour des
missions
je sais même pas quoi dire je peux pas
vous laisser sur ce dénouement sans vous
parler de certaines théories il y a un
arc très sombre de cette histoire qui a
été soulevé par des journalistes à
l'époque comment Douglas a survécu après
avoir abattu son dernier chien certains
l'ont accusé de cannibalisme oui il y a
des rumeurs qui disent qu'il a dû
bouffer Xavier d'ailleurs dans son
fameux journal de bord il y a un passage
un peu chelou un passage dans lequel il
dit j'ai fait bouillir de la viande de
chien mais la date correspond à deux
semaines après qu'il est abattu le
dernier chien et de jour après la mort
de Xavier et est-ce bien du chien dans
cette casserole de glace où était-ce du
Xavier évidemment les théories vont
encore plus loin certains vont jusqu'à
dire que il aurait précipité la mort de
Xavier en tout cas lui de son vécu il a
toujours nié ses hypothèses et sa
descendance les nids à son tour
aujourd'hui mais l'hypothèse existe elle
est intrigante et quand même qu'on voit
les dates des événements on se dit
comment tu as fait après c'est des
hypothèses ça n'enlève rien à son mérite
d'avoir survécu à autant d'emmerdes
autant de galères franchement beau gosse
sacré explorateur le Douglas et écoutez
j'espère que cette histoire vous a plu
moi je vous cache pas je dois être en
live dans 6 minutes actuellement
j'ai un peu tardé j'ai kiffé vous
raconter cette histoire j'espère qu'elle
vous a plu un gros respect à tous les
gens qui partent à l'aventure même dans
des conditions pas du tout aussi
extrêmes je trouve ça assez fou les gens
qui ne stress vont en mer pendant
plusieurs semaines ou bouge dans des
pays qui connaissent pas du tout avec
trois fois rien juste un sac je trouve
ça incroyable ça demande un courage
dingue moi ça me terrorise et donc je
suis particulièrement touché par les
histoires comme celle de Douglas les
Squeezie au sport et vous bien on se
retrouve bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo